[Aplausos]
[Música]
polonia es un país que rompe todos los
estereotipos por un lado es el país más
católico de la unión europea el 87% de
la población de este país son católicos
sin embargo el grupo de música más
conocido de polonia es dijimos un grupo
de black metal abiertamente satánico
pero esperad un momento porque los
estereotipos no se quedan aquí si hay
algo por lo que polonia se está haciendo
famosa es por su gobierno uno de los más
conservadores de europa en los últimos
años polonia sale en medios de
comunicación por noticias como esta
[Música]
judiciales de polonia la unión europea
toma medidas disciplinarias y la más
reciente
el tribunal constitucional de polonia
declara inconstitucional la ley que
permite el aborto de fetos con defectos
congénitos sin embargo este gobierno
tiene muchísimo apoyo popular de hecho
en las últimas elecciones presidenciales
que se celebraron en verano de este año
2020 el presidente andrei duda ha vuelto
a ganar
ahora bien el presidente es una cosa y
el gobierno otra muy distinta polonia
tiene un gobierno de coalición de
derechas el partido más importante es el
partido ley y justicia que por sus
iniciales en polaco lo llamamos el pp y
es esta coalición ha estado a punto de
tambalearse por los aires hace solamente
un mes y diréis porque en algo que ver
con las protestas contra la ley del
aborto es por diferencias en la gestión
del coronavirus pues nada de eso atentos
porque el vídeo de hoy os va a romper
todos los esquemas y todos los
estereotipos que teníais en vuestra
cabeza porque la polémica en polonia ha
venido por esta ley
el partido gobernante polaco dice que la
coalición podría colapsar a causa del
proyecto de la ley de los derechos de
los animales
efectivamente hablamos de una ley de
protección animal que prohibía usar a
los animales en espectáculos tenerlos
atados durante más de 12 horas al día y
un montón de cosas más hablamos de una
ley de protección de los animales mucho
más garantista que la de muchos otros
países europeos y diréis quien ha
propuesto esta ley pues nada menos que
ladislao kaczynski
y diréis pero y quiénes kaczynski ngg
pues nada más y nada menos que el hombre
más importante de la política polaca
quizás si os digo esto pensaréis que es
el presidente o el primer ministro
verdad error craso error ya os digo que
este vídeo os va a romper todos los
esquemas porque hasta hace unas pocas
semanas el señor kaczynski era
únicamente un ex primer ministro de
polonia sin embargo que asistiese a
polonia lo que álvaro uribe es a
colombia un político muy influyente
incluso cuando no gobierna y al igual
que uribe
kaczynski también se sitúa a la derecha
del espectro político pues bien
kaczynski ha sido quien ha gastado todo
su capital político para sacar esta ley
y diréis pero por qué son tan
importantes los derechos de los animales
en polonia porque esta ley puede dar al
traste con la coalición del gobierno hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
radiografía de la derecha polaca si
hablamos de política polonia es un caso
muy pero que muy interesante
[Música]
veréis la mayor parte de los países
podríamos decir que hay por un lado una
izquierda socialdemócrata y por el otro
una derecha que puede ser más o menos
conservadora o más o menos liberal sin
embargo en polonia tenemos un centro
derecha o derecha moderada que sería la
plataforma cívica creada por donald task
este partido forma parte del partido
popular europeo
en el otro lado tenemos a una derecha
mucho más conservadora y con ciertos
tintes populistas en este caso estamos
hablando del partido ley y justicia que
es quien gobierna polonia desde 2015 en
otras palabras que el debate político en
este país es entre derecha y más derecha
y dentro de esta derecha más derecha que
es la que está ahora mismo en el
gobierno hay una persona que es el
factótum de la política polaca y ahora
si hablamos de jaroslaw kaczynski
kaczynski no hay un dirigente en nuestro
país
polonia es una democracia nuestro primer
ministro encabeza el gobierno el
presidente cumple sus funciones pero
queda algo de margen para el jefe del
partido efectivamente desde hace 20 años
kaczynski es el líder incansable del
partido ley y justicia y cuando dicen
que le queda algo de margen para
gobernar desde este cargo que en
principio nada tiene que ver con el
ejecutivo es porque el primer ministro
actual es un acólito de kaczynski y el
presidente and rey duda también fue
promovido por ley y justicia vamos que
en esta fiesta de la democracia todos
vienen de la misma familia y no estoy
hablando en términos metafóricos sino
estáis muy al tanto de la política
polaca de los últimos años preparaos
porque os vais a quedar boquiabiertos a
ver como lo digo imaginaos que en una
democracia semi presidencial el primer
ministro y el presidente no solo vienen
del mismo partido sino que atentos
tienen la misma cara así como yo digo
tienen la misma cara vamos que que son
iguales y aunque eso parece lo de menos
también tienen el mismo apellido como
resolvemos eso
entre 2006 y 2007 polonia estuvo
gobernada por hermanos gemelos
literalmente él es casi el accidente y
jaroslaw kaczynski era el primer
ministro supongo que se pondrían de
acuerdo entre ellos para no llevar la
misma corbata porque si no imaginamos el
cromo no se les podría distinguir pero
la historia no termina aquí porque los
hermanos kaczynski ya eran famosos en
polonia antes de haber entrado en
política cuando tenían once años
actuaron en la misma política y por
supuesto también tomaron juntos
con historias como esta es normal
entender que los kaczynski tuvieran el
cariño de todos los polacos
[Música]
en el año 2001 fundaron juntos el
partido ley y justicia por sus siglas en
polaco
y es un partido conservador que bebe
directamente de los valores católicos
pues bien en sólo cinco años este
partido llegó hasta el gobierno y así es
como los gemelos kaczynski se hicieron
con casi todo el poder en su país el 1
como presidente y el otro como primer
ministro que me pregunto yo si no se
llegaría a intercambiar algún día sin
embargo esta historia familiar tan
bonita tuvo un final terrible de hecho
hablamos de una de las tragedias más
tristes de la política internacional
[Música]
smolensk la tragedia que definió la
política polaca el 10 de abril del año
2010 les kaczynski viajaba en un avión
junto a muchos otros políticos el
presidente del banco central el ministro
de asuntos exteriores el de cultura y
muchos más pues bien cuando sobrevolaban
la ciudad rusa de smolensk el avión se
estrelló y murieron todos los pasajeros
desde entonces y el bluff kaczynski es
el único líder indiscutible de la
derecha polaca nunca volvió a ocupar un
cargo público pero a la vez es él quien
toma las decisiones más importantes en
el seno de su partido
esto significa que maneja la política
interior y la política exterior de
polonia y sino como me explicase que un
señor que no tiene ningún cargo formal
en el gobierno pueda tomar decisiones
como esta
desde polonia kaczynski dice no al euro
durante su campaña electoral además
aunque es verdad que no ostentaba ningún
cargo sí que tenía bastante libertad
para promover o quitar a los candidatos
a la jefatura del gobierno tanto es así
que algunos medios hablaron de primeros
ministros desechables
si alguien dejaba de convencer a
kaczynski por lo que fuera perdía su
cargo este fue el caso por ejemplo de
marczynski bits en 2006 o de beat asiduo
en 2017 ahora mismo el primer ministro
polaco es matheus moravia skin que de
nuevo es muy cercano a kaczynski y
diréis peri quien apoya este partido
pues nada más y nada menos que la mitad
de los polacos al menos si nos guiamos
por los resultados de las elecciones
parlamentarias de 2019 y las
presidenciales de 2020 como veis aquí en
visual politics sí que nos creemos los
resultados de las elecciones y diréis
pero y cómo es la base tradicional de
votantes de ley y justicia pues como os
podéis imaginar hablamos de gente muy
conservadora que normalmente vive en
zonas rurales y que está muy influida
por la iglesia católica recordad que
estamos hablando de un país en el que la
religión es una cuestión muy importante
el 90% de los polacos se declaran
católicos
es una de las 10 emisoras de radio más
escuchadas es radio maría dirigida por
el sacerdote thaddeus beats y a su vez
esta emisora también está muy vinculada
a la ley y justicia tanto y hasta el
propio vaticano se ha pronunciado sobre
el uso político que este sacerdote hacía
de radio maría y de la religión así que
ya os podéis imaginar que las ideas de
kaczynski son más o menos lo contrario
de liberales hablamos de una derecha muy
conservadora muy católica que está en
contra del aborto y que tampoco ve con
buenos ojos la llegada de los refugiados
o los derechos lgtb de hecho otro
escándalo made in pool and muy reciente
se dio cuando un centenar de pueblos
polacos se proclamaron zonas libres del
gp son declaraciones que no tienen nada
que ver con la ley pero sí con la
retórica del gobierno
kaczynski llama a los derechos de lgtb
una amenaza para polonia como os podéis
imaginar a la unión europea no le ha
gustado nada esta idea de los pueblos
anti gay y ya ha anunciado que les va a
retirar la financiación esto podría ser
todo un varapalo para polonia hablamos
de uno de los países que más fondos
europeos recibe podéis pensar que estas
son las razones que explican que la
coalición de gobierno se tambalea un
poco verdad pues para nada ya os he
dicho que en este vídeo os vamos a
romper los esquemas en realidad las
discusiones en el gobierno polaco vienen
por otro asunto totalmente distinto
atentos
[Música]
y extraños compañeros de cama cuando
hablamos de polonia normalmente pensamos
en ley y justicia el partido de
kaczynski está en el gobierno y tiene
muchísima presencia en los medios de
todo el mundo lo que nos sale en tantos
medios es que el ps no gobierna sólo lo
hace en coalición con otros dos partidos
uno se llama acuerdo y el otro polonia
solidaria quedaos con estos nombres
porque van a ser muy importantes a lo
largo de este vídeo
os podéis imaginar los dos partidos más
pequeños son de ideas muy próximas a las
del pp y ese eso sí numéricamente no hay
punto de comparación y la injusticia
tiene 198 diputados en el saint que es
como llaman al congreso en este país
estos dos partidos suman entre los 237
diputados y todos estos partidos juntos
estos 235 diputados se constituyen en el
grupo parlamentario derecha unida pues
bien esta armonía conservadora estuvo a
punto de estallar en septiembre de 2020
y el origen de la batalla no es otro que
la sucesión de ladislav kaczynski esto
explica que en la prensa polaca
encontramos tantas noticias como esto
[Música]
se obró actúa como un primer ministro
autoproclamado dentro del gobierno
polaco la cola mueve al perro y os
preguntareis y en ese 'talde' y hombro
pues ni más ni menos que el líder del
partido polonia solidaria que como ya
sabéis gobierna en coalición junto con
el país además es el ministro de
justicia así que las reformas judiciales
tan polémicas que han sacudido a la
unión europea son en gran medida mérito
suyo veréis si alguno de vosotros os
puede parecer que kaczynski es muy
conservador si obró le gana por la
derecha su partido está en contra del
aborto del matrimonio homosexual y del
convenio de estambul contra la violencia
contra la mujer porque dice que se trata
y cito textualmente de una creación
feminista para justificar la ideología
que y si el partido deseo pero
representa el ala más conservadora del
gobierno en el otro lado de la balanza
tenemos el partido acuerdo de jaroslaw
gov y es que si se llama así acuerdo de
years what going para que quede bien
claro quién es el que manda bueno pues
tanto polonia solidaria como acuerdo son
partidos demasiado pequeños para
promover realmente sus intereses pero lo
bastante grandes para contrarrestar el
poder del país
y como os podéis imaginar a nuestro
querido amigo kaczynski esto no le gusta
nada pues a todo esto sumarle que el
ministro de justicia si obró odia
personalmente al primer ministro
amorabieta y tanto es así que el propio
morawiecki ha llegado a pedir a
kaczynski que destituyera así obró y ya
sé lo qué pensaréis pero si es el primer
ministro no puede poner a los ministros
que quiera pues lo cierto es que no
porque de facto el líder de la derecha
polaca es kaczynski así que es él quien
tiene la última palabra es más en cierto
modo podríamos decir que todas estas
peleas internas son únicamente esa
batalla por la sucesión de kaczynski
[Música]
así es como llegamos a septiembre de
2020 vamos a ponernos un momento en la
piel de kaczynski imaginad que tenéis 71
años sois el político más importante de
polonia pero vuestro partido gana cada
vez menos votos en las elecciones y
vuestra colección de gobierno está
inmersa en luchas internas a todo esto
hay que sumarle la pandemia del
coronavirus en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo los números de
polonia se han disparado pero es cierto
que en septiembre de 2020 el virus
estaba bajo control ahora bien con mejor
o peor fortuna el coronavirus puede
arruinar cualquier gobierno y si no que
se lo digan a donald trump asi que
kaczynski está en una situación un tanto
complicada por un lado le gustaría
ampliar su cuota de poder y calmar las
peleas internas pero por el otro seamos
sinceros nadie querría gobernar ni
polonia ni ningún país europeo en 2020
creo que en esto estarían de acuerdo
todos merkel macrón sánchez y claro está
el propio kaczynski porque nos quedan
varios años en los que el poder se ha
convertido en una patata caliente todos
los gobiernos están aprobando
restricciones muy impopulares mientras
tanto hay empresas que quiebran subidas
de paro y recortes en otras palabras que
la idea de pasar estos años en una
cómoda oposición no suena del todo mal
así que diréis entonces que ha hecho
kaczynski pues ha hecho lo que podríamos
llamar un helmer y político y que
significa un helmer y político pues
atentos porque ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
el gamer y polaco en el fútbol americano
el gamer y ave maría es una jugada
arriesgada desesperada y muy muy muy
difícil de hacer bien ocurre cuando el
juego ya está terminando tu equipo está
perdiendo pero de repente te encuentras
con el balón no tienes a nadie de los
estudios a tu alrededor están a punto de
quitar terol y ahí es cuando haces el
famoso geimer y paz es decir lanzas el
balón todo lo lejos que puedas a ver si
con un poco de suerte marcas un
touchdown
pues algo parecido es lo que ha hecho
nuestro querido amigo kaczynski ha dicho
a tomar por la bicicleta no tengo nada
que perder así que me la voy a jugar si
pierdo me quito tres años de problemas y
si gano pues mira al menos he limpiado
mi coalición y aquí es donde entra esta
ley de derechos de los animales y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos seguro
que sí no tan conservador kaczynski y
estará en contra de los derechos de los
animales verdad normalmente este tipo de
posturas se asocian con la izquierda más
ecologista pues si pensáis así hacéis
muy mal los estereotipos casi siempre se
equivocan y este es uno de esos casos
porque mis queridos amigos de visual
política chin esquí puede ser más de
derechas que el mismísimo agustín lage
pero le encantan los animales no sé con
toda la historia pero resulta que este
hombre está soltero es más hasta el año
2013 vivía con su madre y ahora lo más
parecido que tiene una familia son sus
tres gatos a estas alturas no hay ningún
polaco que conozca el gran afecto que
siente este hombre por los animales y la
verdad es que tampoco lo es dónde
[Música]
si este señor es jaroslaw kaczynski en
una sesión del congreso y si está
hojeando un libro sobre gatos
[Música]
así que como podéis comprobar tiene
muchísimo interés en los animales es más
en el año 2018 ya intento sacar una ley
en contra del maltrato animal en aquel
momento no quiso gastar todo su capital
político para que se aprobara así que el
parlamento votó en su contra pero esta
vez ha vuelto con su proyecto de ley y
atentos porque en toda europa esta es
una de las leyes más garantistas para
los animales vamos esta ley podría hacer
las delicias de una pamela anderson o
cualquier activista de peta
la ley de kaczynski propone lo siguiente
prohibir la cría de animales para
obtener pieles bueno de todos los
animales - de los conejos también quería
prohibir el uso de animales para
espectáculos es decir que si alguien en
españa' se planteaba organizar corridas
de toros en polonia pues ya se puede
buscar otro país lo siento mucho santi
abascal
además kaczynski también quiere limitar
algunos rituales que conllevan el
sufrimiento de un animal y crear un
consejo específico para proteger los
derechos de los animales en otras
palabras que los tuiteros conservadores
van a sudar cuando quieran opinar sobre
este hombre al menos los españoles pero
estereotipos aparte la pregunta es por
qué decimos que esta ley es tan
arriesgada el principio a la gente le
gustan los animales esta ley podría ser
una de estas leyes que pueden encontrar
un consenso en todo el arco
parlamentario verdad porque esta ley es
tan polémica en polonia pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
m
es país para veganos en el mundo hay
tres países que lideran las
exportaciones de pieles de visón china
dinamarca y polonia tal cual como lo oís
si queréis compraros un abrigo de pieles
es muy probable que tenga la etiqueta
made in polar
la industria peletera genera miles de
empleos en este país empleos
principalmente rurales y como ya os
hemos comentado al comienzo de este
vídeo uno de los sectores que más apoyan
al partido ley y justicia es
precisamente ese el del campo así que
mucha de la gente que había votado al
psc ahora se sienten traicionados pero
no solamente hablamos de ellos sino
también de otro sector de votantes
crucial para ley y justicia os acordáis
de radio maría y su controvertido
director tadeusz rydzyk pues atentos
ahora sienten lástima por estas pequeñas
pieles dijo el padre rick recientemente
y agregó que el gobierno debería
centrarse en cosas como limitar aún más
el derecho al aborto no animal hicimos
al hombre y no humanicemos a los
animales pero no sólo hablamos de la
religión católica esta ley es un ataque
frontal contra el islam y el judaísmo y
diréis pero por qué pues porque los
musulmanes comen comida halal y los
judíos comen comida kosher y qué
problema tiene la comida kosher y halal
con los derechos de los animales pues
muchísimos
[Música]
veréis en su versión más ortodoxa para
preparar carne kosher o halal tienes que
desangrar al animal mientras esté vivo y
consciente es decir que no lo puedes
quedar ni aturdir los que defienden este
tipo de rituales aseguran que el
desangrado dura bastante poco es decir
el animal muere a los pocos minutos pero
siempre puede haber un fallo o un mal
corte y el animal puede sufrir durante
mucho más tiempo y todo esto explica
noticias como esto
una región belga prohíbe el sacrificio
de animales halal y kosher dinamarca
prohíbe el sacrificio kosher y jalal de
animales y diréis y todo esto en qué
medida afecta a polonia el 87 por ciento
de su población es católica y el otro
13% es de toda clase de religión es
curiosamente polonia tiene una de las
poblaciones musulmanas más pequeñas de
toda europa para que os hagáis una idea
hay más testigos de jehova en polonia
que musulmanes y judíos juntos sin
embargo polonia es uno de los
principales exportadores de carne kosher
y halal de toda europa no tenemos cifras
exactas pero hablamos de un negocio que
mueve millones de euros al año para que
os hagáis una idea polonia es un
productor tan importante que incluso un
israel tienen un problema con esta ley
que quieren sacar atentos
[Música]
líderes judíos preocupados por la
propuesta de polonia de prohibir las
exportaciones kosher creo que ya os
podéis empezar a imaginar porque esta
ley es tan controvertida básicamente
supone un golpe a su propia base de
votantes al menos los que trabajan en el
campo y como os podéis imaginar todos
los aliados políticos de kaczynski se
han opuesto frontalmente a esta ley y
diréis cómo ha respondido kaczynski
recordad que hablamos de un hombre de 71
años un hombre que representa a las
esencias del conservadurismo polaco pues
bien para terminar de romper con los
estereotipos ha tomado la decisión más
millennial posible se ha abierto un
perfil de 'tik tok' única y
exclusivamente para poder emitir una
vídeo respuesta defendiendo su ley culta
y esto es en serio ha salido en víctor y
lo que dice básicamente es que toda
buena persona debería apoyar esta ley y
luego nómina adivinad a quien a su
predilecto el primer ministro matheus
morawiecki ya lo tenéis la verdad es que
la jugada de kaczynski es más que
sorprendente porque es obvio que muchos
granjeros que apoyaron
en las últimas elecciones a partir de
ahora se van a buscar otro partido pero
a la vez esta ley ha recibido muchísimo
apoyo entre algunos sectores que jamás
se habrían acercado ante esa ley
justicia hablamos de jóvenes defensores
de derechos de los animales y en
definitiva algunos votantes de
izquierdas pero es más el proyecto de
ley le ha permitido a kaczynski hacer
toda una purga en su coalición coalición
que como recordaréis estaba haciendo
aguas
tanto polonia solidaria como acuerdo se
negaron a apoyar el proyecto de ley de
protección animal algunos de sus
diputados votaron en contra y otros se
obtuvieron y quien es uno de los
principales detractores lo habéis
adivinado el ministro de justicia-
zbigniew ziobro y quien ha votado a
favor exacto el señor morawiecki pero la
historia no termina aquí porque cuando
la propuesta de esta ley paso por el
same es decir el parlamento polaco 15
diputados del propio país también
votaron en contra y lo que pasa a
continuación sí que encaja bien con los
estereotipos de polonia
vamos que esta parte no os va a
sorprender
[Música]
por si vuestra polato han de regular os
lo traduzco los 15 incluido el ministro
de agricultura fueron suspendidos del
partido y qué pasó con la coalición en
principio parecía que la ruptura era
inevitable
[Música]
el partido polaco ley y justicia se
plantea gobernar en solitario después
del colapso de la coalición derecha
unida pero precisamente de esto va el
gamer y con un poco de riesgo a veces lo
imposible se hace realidad si la
coalición de derecha unida se hace
pedazos es probable que polonia tuviera
que celebrar nuevas elecciones en este
año 2020 con la pandemia del cob y nadie
quiere arriesgar su cuota de poder en
otras elecciones
así que por el momento la coalición se
mantiene y diréis y qué ha pasado con
nuestro buen amigo kaczynski pues ha
regresado al poder es decir al poder
oficial a partir de ahora es vice primer
ministro la verdad es que a estas
alturas la suerte de la ley de
protección animal no está del todo clara
el senado la aprobó con varias enmiendas
pero parece que las protestas se
enfriaron un poco los ánimos del país
así que de momento el proyecto de ley
está en el congelador del congreso
polaco mientras tanto el gobierno
prefiere dirigir su atención a otros
asuntos como por ejemplo el aborto
recordad que era exactamente lo que
pedía el sacerdote thaddeus read y
diréis al final que ha conseguido
kaczynski pues la verdad es que al menos
a corto plazo él geimer y le ha salido a
las mil maravillas ha podido limpiar a
la oposición dentro de su club
parlamentario y también dentro de su
propio partido y ahora tanto el pei es
como el propio kaczynski tiene una
posición de mucho más poder así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
queréis que el proyecto de ley sobre la
protección animal se llegara a aprobar y
lo que es más importante que pensáis
sobre esta ley vosotros también
prohibiría
los animales y la comida halal y kosher
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre recordad que
tenemos otro canal que se llama
megaproyectos con cada visual politiken
aquí hablamos de los proyectos de
ingeniería más ambiciosos de la historia
de la humanidad y no olvidéis que visual
política en este canal sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
notificaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]